ours et nous les tuche après on est de
retour à 12 heures ailleurs c'est
exactement c'est le moment de préparer
noël en famille mois ce qui se passe je
cours et je voudrais que ma soeur soit
il a aussi problème c'est son mari
secours johri au 8 ça va vous êtes
chamailler là tous les deux là pour des
conneries il ya dix ans alors le marteau
thème toujours travaillé je me régale
ses magasins enfin j'ai quand-même pizza
schéma quasiment jamais livrer une pizza
les fromages pas de pizza trois fromages
deux fois trop ça fait si ce problème
là rabibocher votre ennemi qu'est ce que
je disais déjà devrait lui coûter pas
valais voit lucide du père noël
et il a pu imaginer jouer devant voire
des acquis magazine marteau les gros
gagnants les petits meurent vous êtes
dans la deuxième catégorie désolé
j'ai une proposition à vous faire
voilà mon plan racheter limacher et
fabriquer des jouets hambourg qu'est ce
tu voir tôt que des clous et sabri qu'un
jouet que nous n'avons pas vous pourriez
appeler l'inspection du travail là vous
travaillez monsieur tu ce nom je
travaille pas je suis pas trop vous avez
déjà vu un patron qui travaillent vous
non
c'est les échos tu connais tu connais tu
connais quoi de quoi de quoi ah ok j'y
suis les effets très drôle très drôle
très drôle
[Musique]